Luke here at the outdoor boys YouTube
channel and today we got a bit of a
windstorm on our hands
[Music]
spend a little bit crazy late last night
we had a winstone storm roll in nothing
too crazy but it's been knocking trees
down right left and center and knocking
out the power and causing us some
trouble so we haven't had power since
late last night luckily we've got a nice
fire in the fireplace and I've been
using a lot of that coal from my mind
forward now plenty of plenty of warmth
so no problems there but the real downer
is that we've lost our water we're on a
well and you need a pump to get the
water out
and so without electricity we don't have
any water and you can only flush the
toilet so many times without water and
then you know you lose that too
so that's the real bummer so we are
going to go do something about it my
folks have a condo not too far away and
they're out of town so we're gonna go
mooch their empty condo and we're do a
little condo camping how you doing Jacob
you okay yeah you're as cute as ever
okay we've got Yeti guard the bag let's
go load the car up oh that pine tree
sure has been wiggling a lot today hope
that thing stays put all right guys you
ready to go out a little venture all
right you know we've been really lucky
with this windstorm it's knocked a lot
of trees down in the neighborhood and
and we even had a friend whose house was
crushed by a fallen tree
or made it safe and sound we have
electricity
look running water and we can poop
indoors there you go take a melody that
melody got a mustache
the trapdoor nathan is one of the most
venomous Nathan's in all of Australia
[Music]
are you a trapdoor Nathan
hey are you smiley today so it was nice
to spend last night in a place with
running water and electricity and it is
a beautiful Saturday morning I just
posted to YouTube videos and I'm just
kind of sitting here messing with that
and we've got to find out whether or not
we've got power at the house yet and
I've got to do like a live feed or
something because I promised how it
announced the winner of last week's
giveaway and because of the power outage
and the craziness I just didn't get a
chance to edit it into the new videos
like well we'll figure something out a
bit fun time to get back home though
looks like we finally got power back on
so a little over 24 hours I think but
we'll see we can't salvage this day we
get that door shut
[Music]
all right guys it is good to be back in
my home and to have electricity and just
some normality the wind storm has passed
we got 70 mile-per-hour winds so it was
a no joke a lot of trees down but
luckily nothing nothing permanently
damaged in our house so we're grateful
for that and I'm just sitting here
chillin with Becca and Jacob the kids
are to bed that goes doing a little bit
better every day she's still walking
with a cane or crotch a lot better off
than we were a month ago wouldn't you
say so yeah so things are going good but
I promised you guys that I would do a
giveaway and but for the power outage I
would have included it in this morning's
video but that didn't happen so I'm
going to announce the winner of this $70
Dewalt angle grinder give away from my
knife making video from last week and
the winner is cat daddy fishing or Chris
Rose so Chris Rose with Kent R aka cat
daddy fishin congratulate and
congratulations you won yourself an
angle grinder I'm gonna respond to your
comment with my email address shoot me
an email or message me on Facebook with
your your address and I try to mail this
out in the next week or so but we're
gonna be doing a lot more giveaways is
coming up in this here in 2018 so stay
tuned guys there's me a lot of
opportunities to get stuff but I'm gonna
try to give away some knives and axes
and stuff like that too so any rate
thanks for watching everybody and hope
you have a great week and I will be
posting again next Saturday thanks for
watching we hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you'd like to see more great
videos from the outdoor boys youtube
channel don't forget to click subscribe
we put out new videos every week and
don't forget to hit that Bell button so
you'll get notified when we put out
another great video